- What's your new show Briarpatch about?
- Well my character is a suddenly given
the news that her sister has died.
She was a police officer
and died in a car bomb.
So she goes back to her
hometown to investigate
her sister's murder and
it just gets crazier
and more wild and weirder than that.
She also works for in
a Senate subcommittee.
She works for a Senator
who she's you know,
in having a situation with.
A relationship with.
- [Kelly] Maybe relations?
- Maybe relations with.
- Is that why you're dating Cory Booker?
You are as research?
(Kelly laughs)
- No.
- [Kelly] It was research.
- No, actually.
- You are very method,
that's all I'm saying.
No I just, I had to point out,
I think he's so awesome.
I think this is the reason
why I wanted to put it out
because I think he's so awesome
and I think it's very
telling of your character
to to want a man like
that that's so strong
and so independent, knows what he wants
and knows what's good for people?
He's a cool dude.
- He is a really great, very cool dude.
- But it's also research too.
I'm just kidding.
- It's so funny 'cause we did,
we shot the pilot for the
show in September of 2018
and then Cory and I started
dating in October of 2018.
And I remember when the show got picked
up and we started doing
ADR and we were gonna
film the rest of it last year,
I talked to the show
writer Andy and I was like,
so art imitates art or life imitates art.
I think I have the answer to that finally.
- I know it's so crazy, yeah,
it just sounds like a cool show.
- Yeah, luckily when
you watch the show it's
definitely more cynical
version of looking at politics
and looking at sort of the
world in general, or not.
But yeah, that's not the case
with Cory, thank goodness.
- [Kelly] I know, no he seems really cool.